next up is Rishi cap TV Steven and Evan
you your favorite leverage yeah I love
it I love a rich you love those
questions so she's writing Steven and
evan i find that service minded people
or do-gooders in quotes can have a very
hard time also being paid for what they
do any advice to get over that mindset
hurdle naturally do goodness so again
let's go kind of stigma attached to it
because i just think what we're talking
about becomes natural i think the other
thing i think as well in terms of some
of the community eyebrow answers
correctly reaching because i'm not
absolutes and how do you want to
monetize the do-gooding because I kind
of think probably that's not the purpose
of what year you're seeking to address I
think in terms of this it could be a
habit Annie make a difference so you
could just walk down the street well
number one in innately if you just wish
you with your friends your partner's
they both really important to you what
what are you passionate about where you
could make a difference to torment
people you know young people disabled
people or people less fortunate than us
and then the second thing is you could
probably walk within a quarter mile
where you live and find something a
charity or people working really hard to
make a difference where they could do
with some help now it could be financial
but quite often the best help they can
have because every charity the business
you've got an amazing business kill your
openers you can probably help them run
their business almost like as a mentor
maybe sort of a director time and you
can make a big difference to be
efficient to that business to their
reach and all those of them so I think
we have to be quite creative about what
is what is going to be a real value to
that business and obviously you know in
some respects a part of that is from the
you know if they recruit do good as as
you say
charity workers people passionate about
an issue I think it is fair to pay those
charity workers a fair wage and actually
something you there's are all kind of
rafter things happening to Canada and us
and most developing countries around
still the modern slavery act around
paying people a fair wage and I think
this will become a movement as well
because I think we want to share the
wealth that we crate with a wider
population of people and not just kind
of the executives and I think what you
can do is shine a spotlight to make sure
that those kind of charity workers are
really given and pursuing their passions
yes both obviously fairly treated but
also reasonable compensation for their
efforts and I think that's a key role
you can provide so as you were talking
this business chat happening around it
and she added that sometimes people who
are service-oriented feel bad about
receiving money that it might change
them that they feel greedy for taking
money for something to doing that is
doing good and other people are saying
yes I have I struggle with that a lot
too so as an entrepreneur who's trying
to do good that fear of making money
because they feel like they're being
greedy when they're just trying to help
getting over that mindset that you know
money is bad yeah well Rishi one thing I
for your company one thing I think it's
a great idea to do very practical is you
can do you know a salary sacrifice for
what passion they pursued so if you had
a colleague who've got better than say
thirty thousand dollars a year you could
say you want to give this to a charity
they could name the charity and then
they can get ten percent of that going
every month to that charity so if they
feel and if they're in a charity and
they don't want to get paid for it why
don't you give them a fair wage and then
they can make the personal choice do
they actually want to they give some of
that money back to the charity and the
attraction about that in some countries
there's some really efficient tax ways
where some countries and some government
to gross that money up so I'm certainly
in this in the youth
I think they give up is another
twenty-five percent and there's old
process called gift aid around that so
so not only that would make me feel
really good if I gave as a colleague
working in your company which she I gave
up some of my own salary because I you
know I didn't feel worthy but I knew
that the government contributed more and
made that dollar go further so make
every loony go as far as it can the
loonie mutt strutt Canadians I love the
ladies I think in general just
entrepreneurs don't value their time
enough they don't value their
contribution enough they under the under
price themselves I think most
entrepreneurs should should be
increasing the prices that lead to at
least thirty percent from where they are
right now and a lot of entrepreneur time
asking for money and it holds them back
and it's recognizing that money money
itself is it's just an enabler money
itself is not the angle ever money is
not evil money is not good money is just
an exchange of value and so for those
people who feel like money is evil and
and you're going to be greedy for taking
money it's really just recognizing that
you're providing people with a lot of
value and you've had a major impact on
their lives and that money will also now
enable you to go often have a greater
impact and touch more people and hire a
team and now your team can go and help
people as well keeping your your mind
clear of money being evil and it often
comes from our parents who you know they
feel like money is evil now we feel like
money is evil you have to you have to
break free of that mindset or you're
always gonna live small your business
always going to be small you're going to
make just enough to survive and not
enough to really build something special
and in in that growth is where you can
have an even bigger impact on the people
around you on the community on the world
so breaking through that money is evil
greedy mindset is is important